all right Gigi hi welcome back thank you
it's lovely to see you again you too so
our last talk you were you you had some
interesting things to say about this
lifestyle that that you've been living
you you've been doing this kind of work
for how long Okay well I think the first
time I ever let's say dat U yeah turned
a date I was probably what 18 19 so and
then yeah like I kind of pushed it back
like that never happened
and then it kind of came about just from
needing some money or being caught in
something really quickly or someone
actually introducing their themselves to
me on that Lin you know like I remember
one man told me I pay like I way and I
was just like okay like you know and pay
like you weigh he said I pay like I
weigh and he happened to be a very heavy
man so he was like I pay like I weigh
and I just remember thinking like oh God
you know and I'm in a crunch so you know
but things like that more or less being
approached on that level and then just
like again shutting it out like it never
happened is is this a lifestyle that you
would recommend for
anyone H I believe that it's for women
that are in a
jam
um yeah I think it's if you're in a jam
I think that if you can if you have a
gift or if you got um other choices or
you know you know that your brain can
get you further or that you just need to
maybe put somewhere you should try to do
that first mhm mhm but if you have
limited
options um yeah this becomes a a viable
way to support yourself quickly you get
fast money yeah but the fast money but
uh the I think the mental wear and tear
is not fast it doesn't go away just that
quickly and the emotional stuff that you
might put upon yourself um and the
acceptance that again if you choose to
do this you chose to do this so that's
another part too too it's not so much um
that the other person's fault or the
situation was upon someone else you have
to remember this is something you got
yourself into willingly so I think that
um like when you're 40 or 50 and
processing it it may wear at you just a
little bit differently and recently I
learned that your your daughter is doing
the same thing yeah how do you feel how
do you feel about your daughter
following mom's footsteps H I feel like
she's just going for a shortcut like
she's not um going to school getting a
degree yeah she's doing she's just
taking the easy way out cuz she saw the
money and that's it so I kind of look at
it like it's a cop out cuz I think she
has a brain she could use it or like I
said you can do eyelashes something but
yeah there I think it's a cop out but I
don't say anything either because again
like I said
um that's my feeling but that's not my
judgment I do it so I don't don't have a
place to judge her
mhm and you you've been doing it for
quite a while yeah uh like I sprinkled
it on and off but I really started
getting into it like um I got in a strip
club and then when Craigslist that's how
I got truly introduced to it and then
from Craigslist to Red Book the arrows
and all that stuff when it was still
where you could just upload pictures of
yourself on a with your phone number
your real cell phone number practically
and just let a rip all day and and then
that kind of you know I was there when
Craigslist got shut down and they
stopped and I was like my income like it
is for these other girls now all that
other stuff I guess the um I forget
what's that camera thing that they're
all doing but yeah only fans yeah only
fans exactly so that was my only fans
and then they got shut down and then and
I had the club the whole time so I was
stripping the whole time but doing this
on the back end and uh I actually met a
Lettin pimp who actually liked me and we
would he would see me and pay me for
dates actually but he had girls and he's
the one that told me like you know you
need to I'll post your first ad for you
you should just try it like you'll make
more money than in here and he literally
did my ads for me never took a dollar
from me and just did my ads and before
it was over I was just hooked to like
yeah and I was very scared at first but
I did it and then once I got the hang of
it and learned how to filter the calls
knew what to listen for knew how to talk
to them on the phone cuz um yeah I
learned to this was a trick I always had
and this is for anybody this is uh yeah
if you're doing a negotiation over the
phone or even if you're iffy about the
person in real life you tell them I need
you to pay a bill and you whip out if
you have a bill almost all of us have
bills pull out a bill no cop is going to
pay a bill they're not going to
immediately say oh and I even say it on
the phone like oh yeah I just need to
pay my cable bill you're tring you're
trying to screen the trick to make sure
it's not and they'll click and hang up
because I say no I don't need any money
I just need to help me out with my cable
bill and they'll just immediately hang
up or oh I don't do that yeah right but
anybody else that is a real date they
will say oh you just want your cable
bill p I'm on my way you know that's how
I learned to filter you have to learn
how to speak or that gray area where
they cannot oh I just taught myself I
knew like okay one
okay um this is where I'm at with that
there's a gray everybody's mother you
know we have moms or your mom might even
be married to your dad maybe your dad
doesn't want to give her that 200 bucks
for the dress so she might get a little
fancer do a little something extra and
then your dad's a little bit more likely
to give her the 200 bucks for the dress
and it has nothing to do with
prostitution but it has something to do
with her doing something more to get him
excited enough to where he gives her the
money put him in and and yeah and
even single
women they may be with a man and say
like I need you help me with with the
bill this is not prostitution so that's
what I learned I said okay start saying
that you need help with a bill and this
will edit those calls right out like
they're hanging up in your face it's
interesting yeah but what what kind of
things have you learned about the
different races because that the you
know I've heard so many girls say I
won't date this type of guy I won't date
you know these guys are easy these guys
are to be worried about
um okay for me the
uh like okay as far as um Arabs I find
are probably the most volatile for me it
is my personal experience there on the
same thing as a black man um but there
are two different reasons why I think uh
for an
Arab
uh their culture teaches them already
that I'm subhuman or because I'm a lady
I'm different or I need to obey and then
all of their Rel religious things and
stuff I think come into play and the
prostitution I think that the respect
level is zero To None when you're dating
them unless you build a rapport with
them they like you something has
happened here where now he's not looking
at you like you are um something that
should be a rock should be thrown at it
okay and then with African-American men
I find it's just maturity level I find
within the African-American Community
there's a lack of maturity in African
American men um I feel like it's
um uh repeating our Groundhog Day of the
Heyday so if they were balling when they
were 20 they cannot let go of it now
that they're 40 and broke they're still
going to try to live as this 20-year-old
man in the same clothes same kind of
outfit looking for the same kind of car
same kind of woman too he refuses to
accept that now he's 40 he's going to go
for the same kind of girl he's going for
when he was 20 and it was going good for
him uh there seems to be a lack of
reality and like I said it's a maturity
thing but I find that it seems to exist
very much I think um an africanamerican
men I think
um the need to
uh to keep that time going or the
happiness even if it is a farce I think
it's some kind of py olical thing that
they have I haven't really gone into
that too deep but from what I can see
it's just trying to relive something
that's now over because and it's a lack
of accepting the future too maybe
it's I think a lot in our community too
we have a thing about the future but
that's another dialogue and that's me
too
um future for a lot of African-Americans
is relative and I think that that's
where that comes into trying to live in
the moment and that let go of this
moment ever I think is something that
African-Americans have because for them
sometimes future is they cannot see it
or can can you clarify that that's
interesting I think that uh
okay um we can go on a tangent here yeah
well I can Spur off in multiple ways to
kind of get to it but I'm going go with
um I think that for African-Americans
sometimes um we are living our
stereotype or we're living what we're
fed that uh my future doesn't really
exist that my future will be a struggle
and to acknowledge that future is just
struggle why would I want to get out of
the moment of the party why wouldn't I
want to live in the party my birthday
party or the time when it wasn't
struggle for me so I think for a lot of
African-Americans it's like
a it's a protective mechanism
and it's also
um I don't know it's just something to
make you feel okay is it because like
long long-term gratification seems to be
something
that a lot of African-Americans don't
grasp um because they're not very
hopeful for their Futures yeah and I
think the sense of even seeing yourself
in the future maybe doesn't exist I find
it very strange that Asians and Latins
can draw so well but African Americans
can't there's something to that the
visual for us the mental visual I don't
know if it's been beaten out of us or
taken away or
that we don't believe what's in our
heads anymore that we don't believe that
what's in our head not for all of us but
we don't believe that what's in our head
can be translated into something that
can be of profit or earned or that it's
substantial or that it can exist in life
like there's a Tyler Per for a reason
cuz he believed in himself there's no
other reason he exist besides the fact
that he believed in himself and I'm not
a Tyler Perry fan I do not like Tyler
Perry movies whatsoever there's only one
I like and that's the black woman one
all the rest of them I with [__] Le
kuner buffoonery I don't like them but
again this man exists and he is a genius
in his own way because guess what I'm
more than sure he believed himself and
he saw the future there are a lot of
African-Americans that that would never
like there's no
away but I'm sure that man saw this in
his head so I think for us the lack of
visual or even willing to accept the
picture that's in our head and not being
able to pin it down to a piece of paper
there's something going on there not
trusting yourself and I remember reading
a book
about you know I don't really remember
but it said something about not being
able to trust yourself anymore and
you're in your worst position when you
are no longer able to trust your own
decisions like even when you think it's
a good decision you still question is
this a good decision is this a good
decision that you're you're bottomed out
when you no longer can even trust and it
also and you know people can do this to
you from lying to you and manipulating
you you you no longer accept was well I
wasn't right here and I thought this was
a good person and it's not and now I'm
not accepting you I don't trust my
decision with this new person is this
new person a good person about I can't
judge it because the last time I thought
they were so
it's that and um I think it's a mental
thing um so I think for a lot of black
people to leave the party or the Heyday
and accept that the future may be hard
or that it may be a future of
uncertainty or one that you can't see
because you can see the party now you
can feel it you're happy everything's
okay but when you step out of that box
you're back into the reality I'm black
I'm stepping outside I actually read a
book that even said that black people is
shown that when blacks step outside
their house we release what is that that
horrible chemical cortisol yeah that
just from us stepping outside our doors
we release it because somehow the stress
of us stepping outside is so immense
that we don't even know we're even doing
it so I think that yeah
it's stepping outside of that and going
back into reality and for
I think that's what drug users are and
let's just say that they're in their own
reality that's the same thing they
refuse to step out of the drug use to
step into the reality of life is
hard
um so I think it's a maturity thing and
like I said anybody who's mature to
again maturity will teach you that it
doesn't matter if it's hard I gotta get
up I pick my britches up yeah at some
point I gotta leave the club even if I'm
drunk and can't drive my car home at
some point I need to accept it I need to
get out of here and I got to go home and
I think for other people it's just like
no bro I'm just going to sit here I
don't know what to do like I'm cool and
um I think that it's yeah it's
uh it's in you
it's I don't know and I think it also
can be taken from you to you may have
had it in you and then got taken away
but it's for every individual person but
I find that in certain
cultures um it's more real um I have a
belief
about African-Americans and
success a lot of people may not
understand what it's like to be a
successful
African-American um or understand maybe
why for some of
us we don't try or and we might
psychologically not even understand it
too as African-Americans to be
successful is to put myself at
risk even more risk than it is being a
poor black person person now I'm
susceptible being robbed killed followed
home and this is for certain this is not
like in another Community if I am a
welltoo African-American other
African-Americans are well aware of this
and they are looking at me and going
she's doing good and the Eminem Soulfood
man was followed home I'll never forget
this is the actually still hurts me in
my heart they killed him in his driveway
this is a man who brought soul food to
everybody like Dar near and it's the
best soul food we could have in La they
followed that old man home and killed
him in his driveway so for I think
people don't understand too for
us and you may say oh it's BS but no why
would we want to put ourselves in more H
it's a psychological thing but to accept
success and to be successful we then
have to accept that I can be murdered
because I actually succeeded and it's
not just by my own kind it can be a
misinterpretation of a neighbor it can
be an officer who wondering why I'm over
here uh it can be a person thinking why
are you in this car I am now stepping
from one danger zone to another danger
zone and maybe the first danger zone I'm
really already comfortable with and I
don't really want to jump into another
one and figure this one out and navigate
through this one and then with the rest
of my life just because I want it to be
successful and I think a lot of people
don't comprehend that and they'll say
[__] it's a cop out well if you
don't live in Los Angeles maybe you
don't quite understand what it's like
and
I first 48 will show you and I have seen
a couple of them where it's the only
successful man in town and poor man it
you're a victim you're putting yourself
In Harm's Way sometimes by being
successful and I say especially in our
community being an African you think
Tyler Perry's just walking around with
no bodyguards P Diddy you think they're
just walking around you think that no do
you think that they just drive home and
don't look behind their
shoulder no I think that their height in
reality compared to maybe Ashton because
maybe it's the same but I would think in
my mind that there may be a difference
there that the sense of me needing to
protect myself now that I'm wealthy is
going to be on protect not even my
wealth protecting my person like my life
my so I can see the next day um I think
that comes in too so these are all
factors that come in I think for ethnic
people are in my community to that kind
of lead to lack of success or
maturity or
progress
H you got a lot going on in your head
huh you've got a lot going on in your
head yeah you got to figure it out and
again because
um you
know sometimes people will say oh facts
are prejudice or you'll State a fact and
somebody say that's Prejudice a fact
can't be Prejudice it happened it's a
fact that's the reality of it it's not
Prejudice um so being an
African-American and sometimes some
people have said things about
African-Americans get hit with a little
truth there and you're just like okay
hold up but you need to figure that out
like why is
that why is that and sometimes it is at
a fault and then sometimes it's a
psychological maybe it's a social
problem maybe it's something else but
when you see a problem and you know it's
true you shouldn't sit there and be
insulted you should maybe try to that's
what I've done maybe with a lot of these
things especially try to maybe figure
out why that is true and why did it hurt
my little feelings and you'll come up
with the things that I've come up and
just said too so that's where I was at
with that cuz sometimes
um yeah some you know there's truth in
life period and it hurts
a lot of people don't like looking at it
yeah um I think the gist of us that's
the world we're living in now period the
truth
is yeah the truth is like if you're
walking in with the truth it's like
you're a party
pooper you think we're getting better or
worse I
think I don't know because all I knows
what I see and what I'm fed and I only
live in California and
California I would hope but it's not the
example I know that people want to all
be like us so that's what scares me
so that if everybody falls in with this
California [__] because the gang banging
is already International which I find
absolutely absolutely ridiculous like it
should just stayed in California if
you're a gang member and you're not from
California like you're slow so like I
don't get that so it's like yeah I see
how what whatever happens here is a
spread and I think TV so I would love to
think that what I see is not real as far
as the rest of the world because I think
that especially in other countries this
just doesn't exist so um I think as far
as America is yeah it's getting worse I
think the rest of the world though as
much
as God bless cies that kind of stand on
their own and don't become Americanized
and stuff because
I find that yeah tradition is probably
the only thing that's going to keep them
from this hurdling Avalanche thing
because the lack of tradition and all of
this stuff gives people just the street
and television to live and it's just
ridiculous it's like yeah
interesting and the work you do
prostitution this is something you think
should be legalized oh yeah to change
the topic yeah I think so
um I think that if uh prostitution was
legalized
um it would be a different world we're
living in
um women would be empowered uh to a
different
level
um my belief is that there's
um again every man like a has a Dream
Woman and this dream woman they probably
would give everything to throw their
best suit in a puddle so she could walk
through it in her little fancy shoes and
um the only reason why prostitution
isn't legal uh I believe especially in
America is because of the fact that uh
women would be equal if not on top um
women would have a lot more power yeah
and if not be given it I mean literally
like um women would be able to negotiate
more with themselves and not even that
um I think that the men who own these
companies and stuff might be able to be
more
um
uh open about what they like and um
without feeling like okay there's a
legal like I'll get in trouble for this
I think that the men that own these
companies will be able to maybe help
women out more than they do already
because they can't have an association
via
prostitution um or it put them in
positions that
they where they could help them out
where maybe you don't need to be a
prostitute let me see how you work as a
secretary and it wouldn't be a big deal
everybody oh you picked up a prostitute
and made it a secretary like it's okay
like I'm trying to help her out like it
wouldn't be this
um you know stigmatism on the
prostitution part so far and I I think
the women would be more empowered and
they would
probably I think again men would
probably give women things and they'd
probably be on a different level and be
able to barter on a different level and
um
uh it probably would even be a slightly
Kinder world I think too if you let
women have more position in it and um
what I have
found for some people prostitution
or a form of prostitution can actually
be
therapy and this may be crazy to say
this but um I know that a lot of people
that maybe I have seen more than once or
something we have a relationship and
it's not just about it's an Escape From
what they have going on so um they're
able to
decompress uh and get back to life or
back to their family
or um just talk to someone that has
nothing to do with what's going on with
their every day so um I think on both
ends people would be at a benefit I
think especially women I think the only
reason why too it's illegal is because
um men know that women would be on top
men will give women anything they'll
give them Rolls-Royce and before you
know women will be acquiring wealth in
abundance and uh you can't have maybe
necessar just all these women running
all these companies and we are kind of
emotional so yeah it would be just a
whole different world but but as as uh
the divorce attorney James seon that I
interviewed uh earlier like La Last
Summer he's in New York and he said that
I asked him if if a
woman's sexual attractiveness is the
ultimate commodity in our society and he
said absolutely yeah I think more than
money more than power more than
anything well yeah because
um I think with all those things she
gains all those things the more
attractive she is she gains all those
things those things are just in like she
can just touch them they're just there
to be grabbed at because someone's just
going to hand it to her offer it or
she'll be next to it even if someone's
not offering it to her men who like this
type will be next to her therefore
she'll be able to be in the same
presence as these people to access those
yes exactly but by by making by making
prostitution
illegal it it blocks a lot of women from
being able to access a lot of the things
that a lot of Tears were men are a lot
of manown Tears you know Commodities
that are so valuable yeah and um I
think the only problem I think anybody
could probably say is taxes like you
couldn't really tax it but I think taxes
are a problem anyway so as far as that I
think if any kind of like legal real
reason would be taxes because you don't
know do you think when a woman is
married uh that's still a form of
prostitution I believe if you have a
shitty husband
yes if you have a shitty husband yes you
probably do have to prostitute yourself
to get what you need for your children
via the husband I'm not saying outside
but yeah exactly you need
to get him to do something more just
like you know he's just not with it yeah
so if you have maybe not the best
husband I think that okay I think a lot
of women marri and
it's if people don't want to accept that
it's prostitution I mean lot of us have
seen
marriages and yeah you're like what is
they don't match and yeah so um all I
know is a lot of the girls I interview
will will tell me so many of their their
clients are uh are married oh yeah oh
definitely probably most of them uh the
just of them I don't know how many rings
I used to look at the strip club it was
just endless it would just it just would
be like ring ring ring ring ring ring
ring um
yeah even with doing the dates I would
see the Rings and stuff or sometimes
they try you see the little
Shadow but
um H some husbands actually tell their
wives and I don't know I mean that's
between them twoo and I've gotten calls
and
yeah yeah I don't know I've had wives
ask me who are
you
and I literally I don't feel it's my
place um I I tell them that they need to
ask the person whose phone it is who I
am and I'll tell them that like I've had
them balling and crying please please
please and I'll tell her sweetie you
need to ask the man whose phone it is
who I
am and I'll just leave it at that and I
don't want to be BS them either cuz
they're women and if it was me on the
other end I wouldn't want to be bsed but
I would want and I wouldn't want to be
disrespected either so I just do it in a
way that I would want someone to at
least give it to me without putting the
person either out so I just tell them
you need to talk to the person whose
phone it
is yeah that's about
it and your your your personality is so
likable you're so attractive I I assume
you must have a lot of
regulars um I have that I've kept since
I was like 25 which is kind of cool for
me I think that this stuck with me since
I've been pretty young so I have um well
I had one pass as well um he passed
quiet like in 2016 but um I lived with
him and everything I was fine well taken
care of he bailed me out of gel at least
two
times um yeah he passed away um but I do
have one like a let's see um two that I
see one's goes on tour so like they're
never here CU they're doing all the
cameras and stuff but they just send me
money and stuff and when they get into
town they see me then I have won this
snow mus since forever I met him in the
strip club he's a Latin man and I know
his whole family he knows mine I got
married and he still would help my
mother and my daughter out while I lived
in Washington I didn't even live here I
lived in Kirkland with my husband and he
still cared for me so much uh my mother
was able to call him and he would help
her out and I mean he bought got her a
whole U-Haul so she could move and
everything um we're still we still see
each other
um yeah um I know he loves me um I love
him too but not to the in that
extent
um I went all that Trump stuff was
happening I was totally going to marry
him if they would have come and try to
give him any Boo Boo Boo about it I was
like okay bro we'll get married cuz like
I'm not going to let them roll you up
like you've been here way too long and
it's not going to happen so like there
are sacrifices I'm willing to make too
to make sure he's okay because he's made
sure I was okay like he's paid for whole
Christmases maybe when I didn't have it
or didn't come out for me didn't work
out that year that's sweet that you have
somebody who's that supportive yeah he
loves me I I
am and that's where kind of my own
little regrets come in because I know he
truly loves me he'd marry me today if I
would do it but I'm just not yeah that's
not for me
I've I never I've had a hard time with
marrying anybody because I've been
proposed to quite a few
times and I have a hard time marrying
for somebody for uh anything besides
being in love I got married one time I
we got married actually we met each
other uh we were married 30 days later
so we got married really quick we met
each other on Hollywood Boulevard we
were married 30 days later in
Washington um while you were working
while you were working the streets I was
uh well I was uh living in Hollywood but
yeah I was escort then and everything CU
he eventually asked me to like you don't
go to work like you don't work and I was
just like no I need to have a talk with
you about why I don't go to
work so and that's how he kind of found
out that usually how that comes about
for most of my relationships
unless I think I've maybe had one or two
relationships that I met them and they
were paying at first and then it
actually evolved into a
relationship but um the majority of my
real relationships I have to eventually
have this talk about that's not like I
don't go to work like that or yeah like
I kind of just get help and I need to
explain it so but even my ex-husband he
wasn't with it he was like no I want you
to stop and I was like okay so I did
stop and all this and went through a
whole period of stopping and all this
and coming back and was it easy for you
to go from being a hoe to a
housewife
no I think he would say that
too
um what was hard the lack
of I don't like being pressed for
money and then when I'm pressed for
money I feel like I have an onter let me
go get it and when you tell me I can't
and I have to kind
of go through like struggle I kind of
that's where and then if you can't
provide but you're stopping me from
going so that we can be that's where we
had a problem at cuz you were used to
the regular stream of money yeah I'm
used to having money I don't need to
budget
so yeah he wants you to stop working but
he doesn't support you in the same
fashion yes and this allowance is not
meeting it and yeah so this was a
problem what was the allowance you
needed at the time I think well I think
like all he was giving me was probably
like a hundred bucks a week or something
so that was going to work cut it so I
think like I don't even know what I
would have thought as an allowance just
something measly like my mind 300 bucks
to get a person through the week 250
let's be even that's nice that's not
enough anymore yeah but I think I got
married what 2011 so it would have
worked out in Washington there's not
much to do anyway yeah but you were
making more than that yeah but I mean I
that was that would have been okay
compromise I'd have been able to work
that out and keep myself busy in this
slow boring place so yeah wow when I was
in Washington um yeah now I think that
was the biggest problem
um it wasn't I like being with somebody
I like being in a relationship actually
um don't have a problem with coming home
to the same
person uh just for me finance and
struggle I'm not like my maturity level
there is lacking completely I'm just not
able to accept that I need to struggle
at all when I know I have Alternatives
like for me that's where
I'm a yeah shitty wife as far as that's
concern are you bad at handling money H
are you not good at handling money
um no I think I'm pretty good at
handling money but I do have a spinning
thing like when I get upset I kind of
spend yeah I spend to make myself happy
so MH but I'm learning I'm winning off
that now because I know that
I'm trying to be more minimalist about
things I don't need a hundred if every
color of this one thing like I used to
be that way if I liked it like about
every color and yeah I have about 200
pairs of
shoes so like I I I kind of obsessive
about certain things especially shoes so
I need
to I'm tell myself like you don't need
more stuff especially now that I'm 40
like what do I need more stuff for like
I can use all of this for the I believe
everything I have now is what need for
the rest of my life besides me just
randomly buying clothes and I know I'm
bsing but there's nothing else I really
need like I got what maybe Max 40 more
years of life I got enough shoes to make
it through that I think besides more
winter boots or something you know
something that you use and wear and tear
horrible but there's nothing so I kind
of get my mind lately on not spending
like that um but I've always been a flea
market and rubbish and all kind of like
from designer store to like a woman who
has some stuff on the ground I shop
anything is is it difficult Aging in in
this
profession
uh you're not 20 anymore yeah I think
the for me the Aging part is not it um
you're you're still beautiful though you
thank you very beautiful thank you uh I
think that the the Aging part no because
I find that these young girls aren't
very smart so as far far as that's
concerned and me getting the customer
and keeping him as something and they
have to go out every day and catch a new
one no I don't worry about that at all
because I know that they don't really
have personality they all kind of are
rude and [__] so as far as I'm concerned
like when I hit the block I know I'm
about to whoop these little girl's asses
like I'm going to make a customer of
this and you'll be out here and I'll
probably have racked 800 off of one dude
and you're 20 and I'm 40 but I'm not you
won't see me again I'll be out here
catch one date and I bet you more than
likely I only probably you prably me two
times and you'll be out here all day
so um one thing about aging I think is
kind of funny is like uh just for me uh
and this isn't so much my age but just
me one thing I'm worried about is just
me keeping up with these little girls
and all this weight [__] and I think
that's kind of this this new relative
that everything's surrounded around your
butt cheeks I think that's the only
relative thing for me that's kind of
throwing me off cuz I grew up with
boobies and fake boobies which I've
acquired so I was like it's a different
time it's like okay it's now butt cheek
time but um I think for men to like what
they like I'm doing them great no you're
yeah and for people like butt cheeks
they're kicking ass so there you go you
got to remember there's different types
for different yeah exactly and a man can
like multiple things too because I've
been told multiple times she the first
girl I've ever dated like this and I'm
like okay that's cool or black or
whatever it may be so I've infinitive
amount of times I've been told I was the
first for whatever relative reason so I
was like okay
so I kind of have a way of getting in
there yeah despite whatever's going on
what how do you see the next like five
10 years of your life going
H I want to move to Texas this is my
dream I want to go to Texas right now I
want to get out of
California um my belief is it's turning
in you know everybody has to have a
state where they can flourish All
Peoples need to have a state I believe
this is a Latin
and um a Latin State a Latin and LGBT
LGBT state so I believe that the state
is more geared and the laws are Geared
for s for them to live more and it seems
to be working out so I'm kind of more
interested in going to another state
where again like everybody's got a state
so there states there for everybody I
think in Texas would be kind of cool in
a Southern so I just want my I just want
to go to Texas and
uh maybe open up a thrift store or
something but a span store or something
of the sort because I'm trying to figure
out what I'm going to sell that's not
myself because I I still got to sell
something I don't yeah so that's my
thing right now some Spanx
or Spanx are for women yeah the larger
women to pull it all in the Kim
Kardashian thing so yeah so everybody
can look like a eight I'm thinking this
spins is a big deal and all those in
Waist Trainers and all this stuff that
they're doing all day so that they can
I'm thinking I just need to get a span
store or something of that
sort I'm serious I think it'll work out
okay all right gig thank you so much for
coming back thank you always interesting
thank you I have fun yeah you're amazing
thank you so much you too sir
okay